[Music]
I'd like to do a step touch as I do this
kind of gets the blood flowing my heart
going so we just roll back with our
shoulders hi Kelly
my name is Heather Dhoni and I've been
teaching dance fitness classes here in
Saratoga Springs Utah for several years
really excited to be part of your good
neighbor campaign here in Utah most of
us are trying to help slow the spread of
copán 19 by staying in our homes and
social distancing and my neighbor and I
decided what better way to boost the
morale and the spirits of some of our
neighbors in the community then by doing
a fun workout class okay everybody here
we go so I taught a 45-minute dance
fitness class in our back yards up all
it took was a porch speakers music and a
megaphone and we were able to all
workout from our own yards and safe
distance
I really think that activities like
working out during this time time are
almost necessary if we can get our
bodies moving it makes everything
stronger than our muscles and our heart
and keeps our joints loose but it also
releases endorphins which actually can
make us happier my neighbours really
loved the workout and they left us so
much in fact we've continued doing
workouts a couple times a week in the
backyards all right another way I'm
trying to help is to just try and spread
joy and positivity on my social media
platform
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going